I wanted to show you a clip that was in
the my local newspaper when we passed
out of Santos and they called it the
petticoat to pass out that was actually
its petticoat pass out headlines like
this were acceptable in 1983
that's when Diane Allen became one of
the first women to train alongside men
at the Army's officer Academy much has
improved since then but she says pockets
of discrimination and sexual harassment
remain Diane describes how fellow female
officers shared their me two moments in
a closed online chat group after the
Harvey Weinstein scandal broke three
years ago they absolutely broke my heart
to see the extent of problems not just
women apart the past but are currently
still happening I would certainly love
for the army to have its me too moment
and just acknowledge what happened and
and move on Diane says sexist dives were
standard in the 1980s and 1990s a keen
sports woman she spent a week teaching
male soldiers how to ski on a dry ski
slope they wanted her to come to the bar
each night she said no instead of going
to the room which I'd been allocated all
week I just took my sleeping gear and
went to the room opposite and found
another room that was empty
and went to sleep and I was working by
this dreadful crashing so I looked out
of the window very carefully so I wasn't
seen to see like remember it's 2:00 or
3:00 but to see young soldiers 2 or 3
them kicking the door down to get into
the room that I was supposed to be
sleeping and I watched this and I could
hear them shouting and all that kind of
stuff and I just watched I never
reported it on another occasion she was
among a group of women invited to see
troops put on a show can you talk about
the incident in Northern Ireland as well
because that was also that's pretty
shocking for a civilian it started
really badly in that a chat ran all
naked and bit the head off a chicken
that was like a live chicken so again
you're thinking it's not going to get
any better here it's really not
it got a lot of naked nurse a lot of
sexual innuendo and you could feel as
you often can the tension rising and
whereas normally you would leave you
would simply excuse yourself and go we
can't there's nowhere to go and as it
ended the men surged at us they came
forward and started just grab us so I
decked the guy who grabbed me I hit him
hard and I put him to heaven and we all
ran the Ministry of Defence said we take
allegations of this nature very
seriously and have robust measures in
place to address any inappropriate
behavior sexual harassment isn't
tolerated in the Armed Forces and we
urge anyone who's experienced such
behavior whether serving or veteran to
come forward
Dyanne spent most of her 30-year career
as a reservist intelligence officer the
highlight an OBE from the Queen but she
claims being female counted against her
when it came to promotion
Dianne's now resigned but she's urging
others who face discrimination to make
contact it's not the whole military
that's the problem it's the feral packs
that we can't control and that we don't
actually deal with those groups so when
it does go wrong it can go very wrong